that's what she said we got some good
stuff for you in this episode I love
Canadian whoa seems like you guys are
very suspicious of them reading with
grace oh it's writing with grace cuz I
really don't want to write this whole
thing by myself it's writing with grace
writing with me me my name is Grace
welcome to this episode of writing with
grace first of all you guys are amazing
and continue to impress me so thank you
for your participation in this series
and now onto some super stat in this
last week over half of your submissions
were turned in on the very last day of
the deadline I will take it about 1 in 5
of your submissions made mr. Kevin's
ex-wife the villain so Wow one I did not
know that so many of you were team Kevin
and too a lot of you have some real like
romantic issues to work out on a
psychological level I'm happy to provide
that playground for you also a handful
of you guys really wanted the mysterious
figure at the end of chapter 2 to be
Canadian so let's analyze that for a
second Wow moving on good time for some
super its superlative or as we like to
call them super superlatives for best
talking those two roses in summer they
created a scene in which Marmee and
banana try to pass the time by
performing their two-woman show hmm hey
banana what do you call it when a crazy
cow gets loose
Marmee asked I don't know Marmee utter
destruction banana answered actually I
call it my Friday night they laugh
loudly at their routine no one else
found it as funny though crush did give
a half-hearted chuckle from besides me
crazy cows in Canada are called moose
spoke the new kid Matt he was a Canadian
exchange student and he was as friendly
as I imagine Canadians to be not that
funny though okay
again let's analyze
Wow moving on best surprise surprise
goes to the pocket dragon or her
creation of the lobster principle no not
like a theory where people become
lobsters an actual principal of the
school that pack Lobster half woman's
best villain user Fox Club and Foxtrot
for creating the villain the
orchestrator it is straight up a villain
with a grandma phone for a head kudos to
you your creativity knows no bounds now
on to our super choice chapter it's from
user M Rowan Meyer this chapter is
called crazy like a duck and I raise e
in love with it so the shadowy figure
turns out to be laces brother Jim heaven
small who is quite literally a mad
scientist he broke out of his psych ward
to save her that hits a little close to
home hi Tim my brother who is an actual
scientist and what's happening on freak
week day 3 there are truth quakes and
when they happen someone ends up
spurting out some truth that they have
deep inside of them and it creates one
of the greatest lines that banana has
said thus far in this whole series yeah
it's happening banana cries clinging to
an ancient AV trolley I can't stop it
here it comes
I once called my transgendered cousin
him instead of the inclusive day I'm
sorry strawberry what I love about this
is that there's actually like real
interesting social commentary coming out
of what seems like a very like silly
character so that's cool layers guys
layers and they had a really amazing
incorporation of the don't you dare
fluff that duck line because Jim Lacey's
brother showed up in a duck costume the
mascot of the school turns out is a duck
and he showed up he showed up what sorry
I'm actually turning into a duck he
actually showed up wearing the mascot
costume which leads me to our challenge
of the
week yes we've never done this before
but we're doing it this week we're gonna
do it the duck stop challenge challenge
you guys with me over the next minute to
create your duck mascot costume whatever
is around you wins this is a great
mascot costume I don't know how you guys
did but I'm feeling very confident right
now thank you
did you participate I seriously hope you
did we ear photos at me using the
hashtag writing with grey I would love
to see how you did one minute of your
time to create art I also love the
villain of this chapter which turns out
at the end of the chapter if you go read
it go read it links in the description
there's an
/ that happens when lace starts typing
into her robot diary and we learned that
heaven small is the key and that lace
must be destroyed Wow but the message
coming in on my samsung tablet laces
robot diary is a good friend of yours
and you can vouch for them and say that
they had nothing to do with the hack and
that someone from within their group
actually hacked the school's Wi-Fi to
send everyone in the group the message
that heaven small is the key and that
lace must be destroyed
end message and with the here's where we
are at the novela right now great week
has begun lace and her motley crew are
stuck in the high school for the
duration of freak week she's madly in
love with crash was secretly is madly in
love with her back her literal mad
scientist brother Jim has now crashed
their party in the high school and
supposedly knows how the end freak week
forever but before anyone can explore
that someone is hacked into the school's
Wi-Fi system and sent everyone in the
group a message that heaven smells the
key and that lace must be destroyed what
and also wow wow so here are your props
for next week this is the big chapter
guys it's day for a freak week the day
we've known about since the beginning
it's when gravity disappears and
everything is literally and figuratively
up in the air I'm talking dun dun dun
speaking of dunk dunk done this week I
want you guys to find out who dun dun
dun it we work on that joke for so long
someone within laces group has hacked
the system and clearly does not want
lace asking any questions about freak
week that sounds like a great setup for
a very murder mystery ask chapter if I
do say so this week what we want from
you is to write a chapter in which we
find out that one person other than lace
is definitely innocent of hacking the
Wi-Fi system however you want to do that
is up to you I cannot stress enough how
excited I am about this chapter being
very murder mystery esque and/or mock
trial ass just put it out there you can
read it however you want but I've been
watching a lot of like courtroom dramas
and I am intrigued now on just some of
my favorite parts this week not you I'm
talking about your fan art submission
here are some of my favorite pieces of
fan art or farts then we received this
last week whoa Wow and remember guys we
are taking next week off and that works
out perfectly because I want you to have
ample amount of time to write a really
wonderful chapter for there you have
this entire week until next Thursday to
submit your chapters the next episode of
writing with grace will be up on April
28th so get your fingers and your brains
and your suspicions going make you're
gonna want a calm / brighting with if
you want to catch up with our story so
far and use the hashtag writing with
grace for all of your submissions so
that we see everything please remember
when you post your submissions on
Wattpad to create a new story for each
new chapter and as always you guys are
doing an amazing job my expectations
have been broken completely exceeded
indefinitely and I am just so thankful
for all of your creative abilities being
thrown this way it's really inspiring
and very cool so once again I don't know
[Music]